Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfshark más sobre esto En un momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
solemos pensar que el mundo está
configurado en torno a un grupito de
enormes superpotencias que son las que
manejan los hilos de todo Estados Unidos
china puede que hasta hace poco Rusia
quizás en el futuro La India Reino Unido
pero Y si os dijera que hay países mucho
más pequeños y Aparentemente inofensivos
que de repente consiguen una gigantesca
influencia escala global y si os
hablásemos de países que ni son los más
ricos del mundo ni tienen por qué tener
armas nucleares grandes ejércitos o
mucha población y que a pesar de todo
han conseguido hacerse un hueco en el
tablero geopolítico internacional pues
queridos amigos amigas En este vídeo
vamos a poner varios ejemplos de países
que siendo relativamente pequeños están
rompiendo todos los moldes Pero antes no
estaría además poner sobre la mesa la
clave el instrumento la llave de su
renovada influencia hablamos del
conocido como poder blando y ojo que
esto puede llegar a ser mucho más
importante de lo que te puedas imaginar
podríamos decir que ese tipo de
estrategia o poder consiste en ser
capaces de impactar influir y persuadir
a personas de todo el mundo para cumplir
con unos determinados objetivos para
ello se utilizan elementos como la
cultura los valores la innovación el
deporte la diplomacia o incluso la
filantropía es el concepto puesto al
poder duro Heart Power que es el que se
ejerce a través de la coerción el uso de
la fuerza o las amenazas y chantajes
económicos un tipo de poder en el que
lógicamente las grandes potencias tiene
muchas ventajas es decir sintetizando
que mientras que el poder duro depende
de la fuerza el poder blando lo hace de
la persuasión y la atracción
a ver sobre la influencia y el peso
militar ya os hemos hablado en un montón
de vídeos es un tema recurrente en
visualpolitik sin embargo de lo que
pocas veces os hemos hablado es de como
prácticamente cualquier país del mundo
puede multiplicar su relevancia y su
influencia internacional recurriendo a
la persuasión lo que además puede
resultar todo un chute de energía para
sus empresas y sus productos y podéis
creerme no estamos bromeando son muchos
los países que ya están desarrollando
esta línea de trabajo así que sin más
preámbulo os parece que descubramos qué
países están siendo capaces de competir
de tú a tú con las grandes
superpotencias cómo lo están
consiguiendo exactamente pues queridos
amigos amigas vamos a ir viendo cada
Arista de este nuevo enfoque y sabéis
que lo vamos a ir viendo con ejemplos
concretos arranquemos
Pero antes déjame hacerte una pregunta
eres consciente de todo lo que te estás
perdiendo por no usar surfshark lo
primero y quizás más importante para
muchos de nosotros la protección de
Navegar de forma segura Surf y actividad
internet de modo que nadie puede
rastrear ni robar tus datos bloquea
anuncios y malware con clic web y
protege tus cuentas de correo
electrónico con ejercicio surfshark
Allen recibiendo una notificación cuando
se filtrará tu información personal y
eso eso no es todo usar que es la
primera VPN comercial con servidores y
más de 100 países distintos lo que
significa Pues que puedes abrir a golpe
de clic un mundo de contenidos
restringido Según tu ubicación además
con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
todos los dispositivos que quieras sin
límite alguno tu teléfono la tablet la
Smart TV el portátil etcétera etcétera
Pero lo mejor de todo viene ahora por
ser parte de la comunidad visualpolitik
podréis disfrutar de un 83% de descuento
y 3 meses gratis usando el código os
dejo el enlace en la descripción dicho
esto continuemos
el surgimiento del k-power
uno de los países que más ha aumentado
su influencia internacional y que más ha
mejorado su imagen exterior Durante los
últimos tiempos es sí efectivamente
Corea del Sur aquí visualpolitik y os
hemos hablado de este país en varios
vídeos os hemos hablado de temas
políticos económicos militares y hasta
sociales pero sobre lo que nunca
habíamos hablado es de como este país se
ha convertido a toda velocidad en uno de
los países más populares de todo el
planeta seguro que todos conocéis el
k-pop o las series coreanas que han
arrasado en Netflix Como por ejemplo el
juego del calamar pero mucho antes de
todo eso antes de que el Gangnam Style
se convirtiera en el vídeo más visto de
Youtube de Qué grupos como bts o
blackpink conquistarán en el mundo o de
que la película parásitos ganará cuatro
oscars la llamada ola coreana ya había
conquistado el continente asiático puede
incluso que alguno de vosotros a raíz de
todo este tema os estéis animando a
probar la comida coreana una comunidad
que también se está haciendo cada vez
más y más popular
[Música]
cine música cultura y gastronomía puede
parecernos poca cosa pero no resulta
sorprendente que un país como este esté
teniendo semejante impacto mundial
habéis pensado por ejemplo alguna vez en
los coches que aparecen sistemáticamente
las series coreanas si no lo habéis
hecho fijaos pero casi siempre son
Hyundai o Génesis o Kia casi que
podríamos decir que estamos ante un
meganuncio para una de las Industrias
más importantes de este país y por
supuesto no hablamos solo de los coches
pero esta es tan solo una de las aristas
que tiene esta enorme exposición mundial
una visibilidad que en el caso de Corea
del Sur no ha llegado caída del cielo
todo lo contrario podríamos llegar a
decir que ha formado parte de una
estrategia de estado desde hace ya
varias décadas
[Música]
muchos expertos consideran que el apoyo
del gobierno fue clave en el haliu la
aula coreana de contenidos culturales
surgida en los años 90 por ejemplo en
1998 el entonces presidente Kim de song
anunció el primer plan de apoyo a la
industria halu el objetivo era impulsar
la industria cultural para convertirla
en un gran escaparate del país y no
fueron solo palabras en apenas tres años
el presupuesto público destinado a la
industria cultural se triplicó el éxito
cosechado fue tan rotundo que el
siguiente gobierno el de no mulón
continúa aumentando las inversiones En
la industria cultural de hecho también
se establecieron varias leyes así como
agencias gubernamentales destinadas
exclusivamente a la promoción de estos
contenidos culturales dentro y fuera del
país
[Música]
a ver y sí ya sé lo que muchos estáis
pensando a ver Enrique si fuera tan
fácil como poner dinero sobre la mesa
pues muchos países podrían hacer lo
mismo no te parece
[Música]
Pues sí tienes toda la razón de hecho en
este caso lo cierto Es que la clave del
éxito de la hora coreana no fue
realmente la contribución económica del
gobierno sino sobre todo que el proceso
estuvo totalmente dirigido y gestionado
por empresas y productoras privadas
enfocadas a la obtención de beneficios
digamos que en este caso el gobierno
jugó un papel similar al que tuvo el
estado de Israel en la promoción de las
empresas tecnológicas tal y como ya os
contamos recientemente en visual
económico es decir mucho dinero Para
apoyar a la industria pero le dio a esta
todo el control con una premisa además
muy pero que muy clara tenían que ser
competitivas por sí mismas es decir
tenían que ganar todo el dinero que les
fuera posible y así poco a poco el
estado fue alimentando un sector que le
podía reportar al país mucha visibilidad
internacional fijaos la cultura ha
surgido como un elemento indispensable
de la competitividad de una nación y un
recurso económico que produce valor
añadido para mantenerse al día con este
entorno global cambiante Corea adaptado
la diplomacia cultural como un nuevo
Pilar de la estructura diplomática del
país libro blanco de diplomacia de Corea
del Sur año 2010 y créeme cuando os digo
que se lo toman muy pero que muy en
serio por ejemplo el Ministerio
exteriores surcoreanos realiza
investigaciones sobre el impacto que
esta estrategia tiene en cada país y en
función de los resultados pues promueve
actividades de fans y eventos culturales
otro ejemplo es que el gobierno
patrocina del 20 al 30% de un enorme
fondo de inversión de mil millones de
dólares destinado a hacer crecer y
exportar la cultura pop coreana algo que
como veis no ha surgido por casualidad
[Música]
uno de los objetivos de esta fuerte
apuesta ha sido el de mejorar la imagen
internacional de Corea del Sur un país
que desde su fundación en 1948 ha pasado
por una devastadora guerra y por una
sucesión de dictaduras militares hasta
los años 90 dictaduras Que obviamente
violaban consistentemente los derechos
humanos y que contribuyeron a que la
imagen del país en el exterior fuera
bastante negativa durante mucho tiempo
se vio a Corea como una especie de Mega
fábrica dirigida por sátrapas y enormes
grupos empresariales de corte familiar
que eran apoyados por políticos
corruptos como podréis imaginar No era
la mejor carta de presentación
[Música]
Así que cuando llegó la democracia el
conocido como país de la mañana
tranquila los políticos no solo tuvieron
que ponerse manos a la obra para limpiar
las instituciones también tuvieron que
empeñarse a fondo para mejorar la imagen
del país dentro y fuera de sus fronteras
y ya lo veis dicho y hecho pero sabéis
que hay un par de datos que nos pueden
servir para entender el enorme éxito que
han tenido por ejemplo según la
Organización Mundial del turismo entre
1995 y 2019 el número de turistas que
recibió Corea del Sur creció un 367%.
pasando de unos 3,75 millones a casi 18
de esta forma el turismo se está
convirtiendo en una enorme fuente de
ingresos completamente nueva
[Música]
otro dato que demuestra la influencia
que ha tenido esta apuesta cultural lo
tenemos con el número de personas que de
repente deciden estudiar su idioma
podemos fijarnos por ejemplo en el
número de estudiantes que cada año se
apuntan a los exámenes oficiales Pues
bien ojo con este dato el número de
aspirantes al topic ha aumentado casi un
14.000 % entre 1997 y 2019 en 2019
fueron unos 400.000 aspirantes casi
cuatro veces más que los que se
apuntaron para los exámenes oficiales de
español dele y no olvidemos que el
coreano es un idioma minoritario a nivel
global con apenas 80 millones de
hablantes nativos es un verdadero hito
[Música]
y ojo porque como apunté hay que decir
que España se gasta cada año 170
millones de euros en el instituto
Cervantes básicamente en sedes y
empleados públicos Una institución cuya
función esencial es promover el español
por el mundo Pues bien Qué queréis que
os diga con los datos en la mano La
Apuesta por la empresa privada y los
contenidos competitivos de Corea del Sur
ha tenido muchísimo más éxito sobre todo
si además tenemos en cuenta que el
español es el segundo idioma que más
hablantes nativos y que es mucho
muchísimo más importante en el mundo
pero no nos desviemos
El caso es que todo este impacto se
traduce obviamente en una gran fuente
extra de ingresos para la economía
surcoreana y ni siquiera se trata solo
de eso también es una forma de promover
la imagen política de coreana el resto
del mundo lo que además de aumentar los
intercambios comerciales diplomáticos y
políticos puede ser particularmente
importante en caso de conflicto por
ejemplo con Corea del Norte Es evidente
que las cosas que conocemos y que
valoramos nos importan muchísimo más y
es una estrategia que ahora también
están siguiendo países como Israel o os
habéis dado cuenta de que cada vez hay
más contenido israelí en las plataformas
de streaming pues ojo porque sus
implicaciones son más importantes de lo
que podríamos llegar a pensar fijaos por
ejemplo en esta noticia la cuarta
temporada de fauda bate recortes de
audiencia en Oriente próximo fauda la
polémica serie de Netflix encabeza las
listas de audiencia de los Países Árabes
foda es una serie centrada en el
conflicto palestino israelí una serie de
producción hebrea que ahora está
contribuyendo a cambiar la imagen de
este conflicto en los Países Árabes y es
un altavoz increíblemente poderoso claro
que el uso de la cultura es tan solo un
ejemplo pero no es ni de lejos la única
manera de conseguir
objetivos similares hay otras posibles
estrategias que pueden convertir a un
país recóndito o relativamente pequeño
en población en toda una influyente
potencia a nivel mundial queréis saber
más pues atentos
[Música]
el poder de la billetera
Además del cine la serie si la música
que sin duda son herramientas buenísimas
para mejorar la imagen de un país Lo
cierto es que hay mucha más tela que
cortar un ejemplo clarísimo lo tenemos
sin ir más lejos con el caso de Qatar y
no tranquilos porque no os vamos a
volver a hablar del mundial del Qatar
Aunque lo cierto Es que este evento tuvo
mucho que ver con todo esto que os
estamos contando con una enorme campaña
de marketing político y económico sin
embargo hay todavía algo más importante
que eso Y es que veréis como muchos de
vosotros seguro que ya sabéis cataréis
uno de los mayores exportadores de
hidrocarburos de todo el mundo está
especializado sobre todo la exportación
de gas natural licuado lo que le ha
convertido en uno de los países más
ricos de todo el planeta Qatar tiene
dinero a raudales Y sabéis qué hay una
forma de utilizar ese enorme dinero no
solo para obtener rentabilidad sino
también influencia como ya os hemos
contado en el pasado este emirato del
Golfo Pérsico invierte buena parte de
los beneficios de la explotación de
hidrocarburos que obtiene a través de su
fondo soberano
[Música]
este fondo cuenta con más de 450.000
millones de dólares en activos lo que
supone más de 150.000 dólares por
residente y más de un millón por cada
persona con nacionalidad catarí Pues
bien el grueso de todo ese dinero unos
400.000 millones están invertidos en 80
países diferentes siendo Reino Unido con
unos 40.000 millones el que más
inversiones qataríes tiene por ejemplo
los cataríes poseen unos 12.000 millones
de dólares en propiedades inmobiliarias
en todo el país Además este fondo es
también el mayor propietario de
inmuebles en Londres al tiempo que
también tiene importantes inversiones En
ladrillo en ciudades como París o
Washington DC
[Música]
Lo cierto es que la lista podría
extenderse casi hasta el infinito y por
supuesto No sólo hablamos de edificios
hablamos sobre todo de apuestas
estratégicas por ejemplo Las garras de
Qatar también llegan al terreno de las
infraestructuras críticas este país ha
estado comprando total o parcialmente
puertos y terminales de gas natural
licuado en el resto del mundo y también
tiene participaciones en un montón de
multinacionales sin ir más lejos son uno
de los mayores accionistas del grupo
Volkswagen evidentemente el control de
estas infraestructuras Y su peso en el
accionariado de muchas grandes empresas
le da el gobierno una enorme influencia
a todo el planeta pero un momento porque
ahí No termina todo el dinero catarí
tiene también otros usos digamos más
alternativos
por eso de buscar la influencia política
y social han hecho fuertes inversiones
En el mundo del deporte sin ir más lejos
y seguro que todos lo sabéis que atari
es dueño del París Saint Germain es su
buque insignia Asimismo la principal
cadena de televisión del mundo árabe a
jacida también es catarí Es decir que
Qatar está aprovechando el dinero del
petróleo y del gas no solo para buscar
rentabilidad sino también influencia
política y económica controlar enormes
medios de comunicación grandes clubes de
fútbol infraestructuras críticas y
grandes paquetes de acciones en algunas
de las multinacionales más importantes
del mundo hacen que los catariegues
siempre siempre sean recibidos por la
puerta grande a pesar de ser un país de
apenas 2,7 millones de habitantes de los
cuales poco más de 300.000 son
nacionales y es un uso muy particular
del dinero para lograr no solo
rentabilidad sino también poder blando
ojalá se ha convertido en una de las
grandes capitales políticas del mundo
árabe y la chequera ha jugado un papel
clave sin ir más lejos el dinero qatary
también ha servido para impulsar su
hermanamiento con Turquía y sí es verdad
que Qatar también ha desarrollado muchas
acciones de corte estrictamente político
Como por ejemplo el apoyo a los hermanos
musulmanes o de corte militar Como por
ejemplo regalarle a los Estados Unidos
la mayor base militar de este país en
Oriente medio pero lo cierto Es que la
chequera ha jugado un papel clave en que
doha sea mucho más importante influyente
que por ejemplo Kuwait un país aún más
rico digamos que aprovechar los recursos
disponibles para ganar influencia es
otra de las claves del poder blando os
puede parecer de cajón pero lo cierto Es
que no es algo tan habitual pero amigos
amigas antes de finalizar Este vídeo no
podemos dejar pasar una tercera vía y
los países relativamente pequeños tienen
a su alcance para convertirse en grandes
potencias políticas Además del uso de la
cultura del dinero sabéis a quién nos
estamos refiriendo pues atentos
reyes de corazones
[Música]
otra de las formas de rivalizar con las
potencias más poderosas del mundo y se
acercabanderado de causas justas y
proyectos políticos para hablaros de
estos vamos a poner dos ejemplos súper
dispares Canadá y Cuba hablamos de dos
países que juegan en esferas
geopolíticamente totalmente diferentes
pero que han sabido explotar sus puntos
fuertes para conseguir bastante
relevancia a nivel regional e incluso
internacional ahora bien la pregunta es
cómo lo han hecho pues fijaos en el caso
de Canadá lo que hicieron fue
convertirse en una abanderado de las
libertades civiles y la protección del
medio ambiente por ejemplo Canadá ha
sido uno de los países que más en serio
se ha tomado la declaración de la ONU en
defensa de los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas Y sí vale Ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando a ver todo esto
Enrique suena precioso pero realmente se
puede conseguir influencia internacional
con estas cosas pues lo cierto es que sí
esta puede ser una de las herramientas
clave para conseguirla y Canadá es un
claro ejemplo de ello
este país norteamericano ha sido uno de
los grandes impulsores de importantes
tratados internacionales por ejemplo
está el tratado de Ottawa firma de 1997
que busca la prohibición de minas
antipersonas o el protocolo de Monreal
de 1987 que fija las pautas para la
reducción del uso de los
clorofluocarbonos y así poder proteger
la capa de ozono
[Música]
Y puede que a muchos de vosotros todas
estas cosas os parezcan un poco
relevantes pero lo cierto Es que
contribuyen a crear marca país e
incrementar la influencia internacional
pesado así todo el mundo quiere estar
cerca del más popular de la clase y esto
es a lo que afecta a gobiernos empresas
inversiones productos y también
profesionales es en cierta forma el
marketing de toda la vida ha aplicado a
los países Pero qué hay de Cuba Por qué
hemos metido a un país tan pobre en este
vídeo si encima se trata de una
dictadura Comunista
[Música]
Pues bien Aunque parezca contradictorio
precisamente por ahí van los tiros un
país tan pobre como Cuba que no tienen
ni dinero ni empresas importantes ni un
ejército moderno ni prácticamente nada
de nada ha logrado convertirse en uno de
los países más influyentes de todo
América La pregunta es como demonios lo
han conseguido Pues recurriendo a las
estrategias políticas en un pasado vídeo
aquí en visualpolitik vimos Como por
ejemplo utilizan a los médicos y ese
sería tan solo un ejemplo porque lo
cierto Es que ocupaba mucho más allá y
si este país destaca precisamente por
algo es por hacer unos intensos de la
estrategia populista que podríamos
resumir en los países subyugados versus
Estados Unidos Europa que son grandes
potencias imperialistas y explotadoras
este es un discurso que se ha extendido
y mucho por todo América Latina y
tenemos por ejemplo el caso de Venezuela
donde los cubanos consiguieron incluso
instaurar una dictadura fantoche A
través de Hugo Chávez para después con
el propio dinero venezolano procedente
del petróleo lograr financiar su
partícula Revolución por el resto de
América Latina la idea parece brillante
quizás malvada pero brillante
[Música]
Cuba promovido por todo el continente
partidos políticos grupos de presión
social e incluso foros institucionales
como el conocido foro de Sao Paulo
espacios de donde surgieron políticos
como Rafael Correa Evo Morales Daniel
Ortega o Manuel Celaya la idea sobre la
cual se construyó la influencia cubana
en América Latina fue bastante
pragmática el régimen castrista se dio
cuenta de que la izquierda no tendría
éxito en Latinoamérica si no se
desprendía al menos de Cara a la galería
de los viejos dogmas dogmas Como por
ejemplo acabar con la propiedad privada
o establecer dictaduras proletarias
ahora bien la pregunta es y todo esto
para qué más allá de la cuestión
puramente ideológica qué interés Podría
tener Cuba en exportar su Revolución
Pues bien para muchos analistas objetivo
primordial sería precisamente garantizar
la propia existencia del régimen cubano
y es que veréis con la desaparición de
la unión soviética a principios de los
90 y la grave crisis económica y social
que este hecho causó en el país caribeño
los castros se dieron cuenta de que
necesitaban una red de apoyo
internacional una red que tenía que
estar en América Latina países cercanos
que hablan el mismo idioma y que tienen
más no es la misma cultura y sabéis que
le salió a las mil maravillas y noticia
como estas son tan solo una prueba de
como un país pequeño atrasado y pobre
logró una enorme influencia
internacional fijaos el 50% de la
gasolina que produce Venezuela se envía
a Cuba Afirma un líder sindical de ese
país a la población le llega únicamente
el 10% de la gasolina que se está
produciendo en fin ya lo veis hay muchas
maneras de conseguir influencia
internacional pese a ser un país
relativamente pequeño este no solo es un
mundo de grandes superpotencias
[Música]
desde los contenidos culturales de Corea
la política Revolucionaria de Cuba
pasando por las Macro inversiones
económicas de Qatar o la filantropía de
Canadá lo que está claro es que si se
consigue desarrollar algo de creatividad
con una buena visión global
prácticamente cualquier país puede
convertirse en una gran potencia en
influencia geopolítica y no lo dudéis
todos los países que hemos visto en este
vídeo han cosechado grandes beneficios
con este tipo de estrategias Así que
poca broma pero ahora ha llegado hasta
aquí turno para ti crees que tu país
podría tomar como ejemplo alguno de
estos países para tener más presencia a
nivel internacional crees que este tipo
de poder de atracción es duradero en el
tiempo déjanos tus impresiones por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y hablamos
debate Y recuerda si te ha gustado este
vídeo No olvides darle al botón de like
y suscribirte a nuestro canal Para no
perderte ninguna novedad Ah importante y
recordad que con el código politic
acabado en K podréis disfrutar de un 83%
de descuento y 3 meses gratis en
subshark el link como siempre en la
descripción una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]